and it's been about a month since a tow
truck driver who was killed in the
southwest valley we're talking about 48
year old ryan billet
he was working along the 215 near south
decatur when another driver hit him
and just left those who loved ryan want
his death to serve as a reminder for
other drivers just to be aware when
you're behind the wheel
sasha loftus joins us now live in
henderson with more on their message
tonight sasha
denise ryan's family gathered here today
and they
say that just every day is extremely
difficult
without him around they gathered here to
remember his life
and to make sure the same thing doesn't
happen to anyone else
having a moment of silence for brother
ryan and for others
flashing lights and falling tears mark
this
heartbreaking moment she was absolutely
amazing always funny
always had a smile family and friends
gathered in henderson friday
to honor ryan billet a month after the
tow truck driver was killed in hit and
run crash
along the 215 near south decatur he's
supposed to be at home with me
and he's not because people aren't
paying attention their profound sorrow
also had a poignant purpose to shed
light on the nevada move
over law that's why i call it the
invisible law
but it's time to make this vault this
law visible it requires drivers to
slow down and if possible move to the
far left
any time they pass a tow truck response
vehicle
or stalled car on the side of the road
everybody needs to be
aware of how dangerous their job is
and when they see somebody emergency
vehicle they need to move over they need
to merge they need to slow down
because lives are at stake this simple
action
has the power to save countless lives i
don't want this to happen to anyone else
i want them to come home to their
families
and those who knew ryan say these
efforts to help others
will allow his spirit to live on forever
be with ryan again
we thank you now ryan's family does want
to stress that slowing down when you
pass any kind of emergency vehicle or
tow truck
slow down to at least 20 miles an hour
even if you're in a high speed area like
an
interstate now as for the woman who
police say
hit billet coletta spain she is due back
in court
this tuesday april 13. reporting live in
henderson tonight sasha loftis
8 news now